sure they remember you
well remember her we do and we may get
to see Candace Everdeen back on the big
screen sooner than we thought after a
recent interview with variety while
promoting her new comedy film no hard
feelings Jennifer Lawrence revealed
whether she would ever return to the
world of Pan Am saying quotes oh my God
totally adding if Katniss ever could
ever come back into my life a hundred
percent
I volunteers tribute now the news comes
ahead of the upcoming prequel film
Ballad of songbirds and snakes which is
set to hit theaters in November I am
honored to introduce to you the creator
of The Hunger Games themselves Dean
casca High bottom
meanwhile Jennifer sat down with Viola
Davis for varieties actor on actor
series late last year to Dish more on
the upcoming prequel with Viola starring
in the film as head game maker Dr
volumina Gaul of course the two
Powerhouse performers spoke about the
impact of The Hunger Games series in
Hunger Games was was an awesome
responsibility it felt like I mean it
was those books were huge and I knew
that the audience was
children and this hero and there were so
many different
opinions you know on what is this
basically this action figure for for
children going to look like nobody had
ever put a woman in the lead of an
action movie because it wouldn't work we
were told girls and boys can both
identify with a male lead but boys
cannot identify with a female lead oh
absolutely and it just makes me so happy
every single time I see a movie come out
that just blows through every single one
of those beliefs and proves that it is
just
a lie to keep certain people out of the
movies to keep certain people in the
same positions that they've always been
Jennifer also spoke about the pressure
she faced taking on such an important
role as a young actress and how it
affected her I was really at the height
you know now what is it like almost 10
years ago like eight years ago when when
Hunger Games was out and I I couldn't
really be an observer of life because
everybody was observing me yes and
I could feel my craft suffering I could
feel my
antenna for the business side
suffering and I didn't know how to fix
it I was I think I was scrambling trying
to fix it by
saying yes to this movie and then trying
to counteract it with that movie and
then not realizing that what I had to do
was no movies
until something spoke to me but as
always Jennifer leads with humor when
reacting to the release of a new Hunger
Games movie in Hunger Games I am so
excited about the prequel nothing has
ever made me feel so old by the way that
they're already remaking those movies